generation saying hey these are the
consequences for those actions if you if
you get on the internet and you you post
your naked body like a guy that that's
worth a date but one guy will care and
one guy
but but
do the guys you want care is the
question that's i think that's different
i think the the difference is the the
high quality guys that most other women
would want
he's more he's going to care about these
things whereas there'll be some guys who
don't care but it's likely that those
guys that don't care and not the guys
you want but then quality again is
subjective like would you rather have
someone who just accepts you for who you
are and loves you for who you are and
your history because then porn stars get
married but the numbers porn stars
but here's the thing they need to other
porn stars though
but here's statistically actually not
correct because i get studying here
here's the thing the numbers the numbers
don't lie and actions have consequences
and so we could say oh it's subjective
like what is quality but like when you
it's supply and demand yeah like what
what kind of then why do we need to all
fit into the majority why do we well i'm
very